[Music]
hello and good afternoon and welcome to
i'd like to know
this is our 30-minute gathering together
where we answer your questions from the
word of god
and we promise to always do it that way
always answer your questions as best we
can from the word of god
because you need the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth
and by the grace of god we will give you
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth i'm in the company of two
distinguished gentlemen pastor stephen
bohr
speaker director for secrets unsealed
and pastor daniel gover
pastor of the fresno central seventh-day
adventist church so we have
two very astute students and i'll try to
add what little
bean i can put in the pot to uh uh help
the brother or not i'm c.a murray
associate speaker here and uh we're glad
to be here and glad to have you here
should you like to participate in the
program we ask you to do so
you can send in your questions to
tv at some tv dot o
r g that's tv at some tv dot o r g
and we will try to get to your questions
as soon as we can
interestingly enough the pile is getting
big and thick and that's what we like we
like a lot of questions
we like delving into the word of god so
should you like to get your questions
answered send them in we will answer
them as best
we can by the grace of god pastor gover
if you would open
our program with prayer then we'll get
right to our questions for the day
let us pray our father in heaven thank
you
for allowing us this opportunity to come
together
to pray and to study your word and to
try to answer these questions
i thank you for all our viewers for
honestly
seeking for the truth amen as it is in
jesus
we are told that your word is a lamp to
our feet a light to our path
and we ask for that light right now and
the help and guidance of your holy
spirit to understand it
in the name of jesus amen amen amen amen
well we have a small pile of questions
here
a great big pile in my office i've
mentioned before that it would probably
be a good idea
to have a one-hour program instead of a
half hour program
we could get a lot more accomplished
because some people call and they're
very frustrated because
we haven't gotten to their question but
in a half an hour a week
you know there's no way that we can take
all of the questions in a timely manner
we have a question here
the first one is regarding the flood
there have been so many fossils of
dinosaurs and plant life
that existed during that time that have
been discovered all around the world
evidence of immense size of trees
animals and sea life
my question is why isn't there or aren't
there signs or evidence of humans
is this a question of faith to my
knowledge there hasn't been any
discoveries
of human bones with the discovery of
dinosaurs
there must have been millions of people
that existed during that time
where did the bodies go if human remains
were to be found with the bones of
prehistoric animals
that would give pause to the belief of
evolution so pastor gover
how do we deal with this issue of you
know
fossils of humans and animals
well first of all i think we need to
always remember that
we look at human science through the
eyes of the
bible and not the other way around we
cannot
look at science today everything that
human beings believe through
human science and try to fit that
into the bible now if we are true
biblically
biblical believers we come to the bible
we accept
what god has revealed us and we look at
science
through the eyes of the bible there is a
lot of things in science that
really are there to strengthen our
belief
but even those things are secondary
we come to the word we accept what is
written as is
it is written now there's a few things
we can say
even when we look at what science has
shown
i found an interesting article online
in this website answers in genesis.org
it's easy to find the title is where
where are
all the pre-flood human fossils and the
subtitle is how the global flood
likely prevented many pre-flood human
and mammal fossils
but preserved other types of organisms
in the fossil record this is written by
troy lacy in
avery folly it's august 7 2018.
now they make an interesting question it
says if there
really were a global flood as described
in genesis and they believe
this is a biblical ministry they really
believe there was a global flood
exactly like the bible portrays it what
would we expect to see today
billions of dead things buried in rock
layers
layers laid down by water all over the
earth
and that is exactly what we see
now they show us us something
interesting they talk about the
the catastrophe the the dimension of the
catastrophe that the
flood was and they showed that it was a
basically a marine catastrophe let's put
it that way they say due to the marine
nature of the judgment
we would expect marine fossils to
dominate
most of the fossil record and that
is precisely what we see in the fossil
record now this is very interesting
and it really has to do with the
question here
approximately 95 of all fossils
are shallow marine organisms
such as corals and shellfish
95 of the remaining
five percent are algae plants
and invertebrates including insects
and the remaining 0.25 percent
are vertebrates mostly fish
99 of that 0.25
vertebrae fossil specimens consist of
only one
bone the catastrophe was so great
that most mammals and most beings that
lived
on the surface were completely destroyed
that's the truth
most mammal fossils are likely from
after the flood that's what we find
and they have other other things that
are interesting
and i'm not going to read the whole
thing of course but i highly encourage
our listeners to to read this this
article
and they say the fossil record is
therefore a testimony to the rapid
burial
by sediment in a watery cataclysm of
billions of organisms
this is why organisms are typically
found inside rocks
or rock matrixes they were buried in
sedimentary mud silt
sand or lime that has subsequently
hardened into mudstone
siltstone sandstone and or limestone in
summary
the most likely answer to the question
of why there are so
few pre-flood human as well as bird and
mammal fossils
is that humans were swept away and their
bodies destroyed
during the flood before they could be
buried
as well as because of the mechanisms of
fossil preservation
which favor preserving hard-shelled
organisms over soft body ones
so i found this very interesting and i
connected it with
some a quote we find by ellen white in
patrick's and prophet's page
107 where she says that
when the water subsided god caused a big
wind actually to help those waters come
down
and there were a lot of bodies of human
beings and animals and that makes sense
because
human beings as they saw the rain coming
and cataclysms happening they fled they
tried to go to the mountains
top of big we are told that there were
huge trees
they were the ones human beings and
other mammals they were the ones that
resisted maybe for the longest ellen
white actually says that some
families tied themselves up to huge
animals because they knew that these
animals would run for their lives but
the truth is that
that has made that cause that these
bodies of
human beings and mammals were on the
surface of the earth most likely
and god we are told in patriarchs and
prophets
brought this violent wind and
he buried those bodies and ellen white
even
says this is again patriarchs in
prophets 107.
a violent wind which was costable for
the purpose of drying up the waters move
them with great force
in some instances even carrying away the
tops of the mountains and heaping up
trees
rocks and earth above the bodies of the
dead
she even says that in some places whole
mountains were put on top of these
people and bodies so
god took care of those bodies that's
what we know god
buried them they probably are were not
um didn't what happened to those bodies
probably was not the same that happened
to the other
kinds of creatures on earth that were
existing on earth at that time
so you know it's interesting that
you have so much coal and
so much oil under the earth
massive massive amounts and all that
comes from
organic matter so at some point there
must have been a
mass burial of organic matter whether it
be
vegetable or whether it be animals or
humans
in order to produce the huge amounts
that we use
as fossil fuel for our cars and
for air conditioning etc so there is
evidence
now i think it's important for us as
christians
to say that we're not anti-science
but we are pro-faith exactly and you
know
we can't for example we can't prove that
god created this world
hebrews 11 verse 3 says by faith we
understand the worlds were framed by the
word of god
so that the things which are seen were
not made of things which are visible
so we accept by faith that god created
this world
you know nobody has to find
noah's ark so so-called for me to
believe that there was a flood
no nobody needs to prove that somebody
can live in the belly of
a fish for three days and three nights
for me to believe that the story of
jonah is true
i believe it because it's settled in my
mind because
i have a relationship with christ and i
have faith
and it's a gift of god you know ellen
white tells us that
you have plenty of room to doubt yes but
you also have plenty of evidence to
believe
she says our faith is based on evidence
not
on demonstration amen because if it was
demonstration you wouldn't need faith
because you would have it right before
your eyes
so in answer to the first part of our
question it is a matter of faith
yeah it starts with faith yes and then
you you move on from there
um your point is well taken that
a lot of these creatures we are driving
around
in in our cars you know well this oil
came from organic material
so there is reason to believe now she
also says though the waters came
26 feet above the highest mountain
exactly
which is a quote so things really were
shook up and everything was covered
so when the waters receded and mountains
began to flip and things were moved out
other places
everything got covered and as it got
covered it rotted it went away
i like your statistics i really do
because they really show that when when
you find one t-rex skeleton
or you find something over here that's
just a small
small percent we're pumping out billions
of gallons
of barrels of oil per day just listening
to something just a little while ago
that uh opec uh decided to cut back
uh something million gallons per day so
we're pumping out massive
amounts of oil per day well that's where
it is that's where all that
material is yeah and i like what pastor
bohr said that we're not anti-science
no we actually believe that science has
has done wonderful things for humanity
but
but we need to always be careful to
remember that jesus said that the
kingdom of heaven belongs to those who
accept it as children
you know we tell the story of the flood
to a child they
they make no questions they they accept
it you know
you know they don't say no is that
scientific possible
and i like the fact that to come back to
my article here
they say that with all of these factors
it
is much less likely for there to be
pre-flood human mammal and bird
fossils but it is not altogether
implausible
that pre-flood human fossils could be
found one day
so we may find uh human fossils one day
but there's there's there's a lot of
evidence to point to the fact that
human beings and most mammals were
completely destroyed
in the flood especially when you read
the biblical description of the flood
i mean the waters came from underneath
and from above
and you know it was really something
that changed
the world completely yes and the beings
that were more
fragile were completely destroyed god
did say
i will destroy all flesh that's in
genesis 6.
maybe i can just read this statement
rather long
councils on education 191-192
that puts it all together geologists
claim to find evidence from the earth
itself
that it is very much older than the
mosaic record
teaches bones of men and animals
as well as instruments of warfare
petrified trees etc
much larger than any that now exist or
that have existed for thousands of years
have been discovered and from this it is
inferred
that the earth was populated long before
the time brought to view in the record
of creation
and by a race of beings vastly superior
in size 20 men now living
such reasoning has led many professed
bible believers
to adopt the position that the days of
creation were vast
indefinite periods but apart from bible
history geology can prove nothing
those who reason so confidently upon its
discoveries
have no adequate conception of the size
of men animals and trees before the
flood
or of the great changes which then took
place which is what you were referring
to
relics found in the earth do give
evidence of conditions differing
in many respects from the present but
the time when these conditions existed
can be learned only from the inspired
record
in the history of the flood inspiration
has explained
that which geology alone could never
fathom
in the days of noah men animals and
trees many
times larger than now exist were buried
and thus
preserved as an evidence to later
generations
that the antediluvians perished by a
flood
god designed that the discovery of these
things should establish
faith in inspired history but men
with their vain reasoning fall into the
same error
as did the people before the flood yes
the things which god gave them as a
benefit
they turned into a curse by making a
wrong use of them i think that
synthesizes everything pretty well
the discussion that we've had now
there's another question here
that this same person asks we dedicated
quite a long time to that question but i
think it's a really important question
um the second question is related to the
sacrifices that god had for the
israelites
at the time of atonement the priest was
to sacrifice a bull
for his family before he could do the
sprinkling of the blood for all of
israel
why a bull was there some significance
to that
so why did the priest have to sacrifice
a bull and not a lamb well that's
interesting um
even we find that i i believe that here
the question is more directed towards
leviticus 16 when we're talking about
the day of atonement but even in
leviticus 4
we see that when the priest would sin
he was to offer a bull and this was
one of the sacrifices where the blood
would not only be sprinkled in the out
in the outer court altar and the main
altar outside
but the blood would be taken inside the
sanctuary sprinkled before the veil
sprinkled in the horns of the altar
vincents same thing
when the whole people the entirety of
the people
would be guilty of a sin a bull also
needed to be offered by the priest
so it's interesting you find it actually
in several bible passages that
priests were to offer balls now one
important and interesting text we find
in one of my favorite
psalms it's psalm 22
and we do believe this is a prophecy
concerning
the death of jesus given 1 000 years in
advance
written by david and we see
several details of the crucifixion here
laid out and verse 12 says
many bulls have surrounded me
strong bulls of bashan have encircled me
now you have even actually other animals
here also
like dogs mentioned where you see in the
bible
that there's parallelisms between these
animals
and the leaders of israel that attack
jesus
at on the cross so the bulls
would probably be a reference to
leaders and that's why
the priest had to offer a bowl in fact
in the translation of many verses in the
old testament
the word for bull is translated leader
so why a bull well it mentions the bulls
of basham
those bulls were humongous
they were they were you could say the
king of the herd
so you say the leader of the hurt and so
many times the word bull is translated
leader
maybe we could just give a couple of
examples here
first samuel chapter 21 7 uh c8 could
you look up that one
i will do something first samuel 21
verse 7
and uh pastor gover if you could read
jeremiah 8
16 just as two examples
okay first hammer 21 and 21 verse 7.
turn the page now a certain man
of the servants of saul was there that
day detained before the lord
and his name was doug and edomite the
chief of the herdsmen
who belonged to saul am i in first
sandwich yes
there is the reason why you're wondering
whether it's a text is because the word
chief there is bull
yes
[Laughter]
nobody would guess that unless you went
to the hebrew yeah
so so doing the edomite is called the
chief he called the champion
and he was he was a very close uh very
close to king saul
we know also because he then accused
david and it caused all sorts of
problems
so let's read that jeremiah 8 16 16 says
the snorting of his
horses was heard from dan the whole land
trembled at the
sound of denying of his strong ones
for they have come and devoured the land
and all that
is in it the city and those who dwell
in it so the strong ones are the bulls
so um many times it helps to look up the
hebrew because
words that are literal are used also
figuratively
so the answer to this question is why
did the priest have to offer a bull
because he was a leader
he's a leader yes so basically i think
that that takes care of that question
now you have an interesting question we
only have like six minutes left we
should be able to do this one
and this is how it reads
is consuming gelatin in the form of
jell-o
marshmallows or supplements like vitamin
d
pills a violation of the bible's
prohibition
on consuming swine i've heard that
gelatin
in these products are sometimes derived
from
pork so how do we deal with that
question well
you've heard correctly and
most of the times i wouldn't say
sometimes i would say most of the times
most of the times these products are
from pork
sometimes also they're from cow
most jello that people eat has
an animal origin there is hope though
there are vegan jellos because i saw
that
i know that there exists even in
portugal
i remember when i was growing up my
mother was already
reading all the labels and say hey here
it is this one does not have any
animal in it and it's vegan so
i know that that that is the case i
search it up and they exist here i don't
need jello
personally but i i looked it up and
there's vegan gel if you really like
jello find the vegan ones
for all the rest i would say learn how
to read labels
you know the truth be told there are
some things that we're going to have to
sacrifice and suffer for the lord
other things we're going to have to work
at now i remember
as a young person giving up jello
because it had pork in it
my mother-in-law gets jell-o almost
every day
but irma finds her and it's fairly easy
to find now
there was a time when it was tough yes
but most health food stores even your
trader joe's you're trying to think of
this big one
um whole foods you can get you can get
vegan or vegetarian vegan
jello with without pork so it's it's
doable
you can order it online you go to amazon
you type vegan jell-o you'll find a
bunch of brands there
you know none of this is really a
temptation for me because i don't like
jello okay
and you know i'm not a marshmallow fan
either
uh which there are also marshmallows
you know the world is such people
understand there's a market for most
things
a lot of people want to be healthy so
just about everything that you can buy
with pork you can get something without
pork yes and
even for the capsules of a lot of pills
that are now also uh there's a lot of
companies producing these
uh that are in and they do not come from
pork or from
bovine origin they're vegan so
just need to get informed and yeah well
let me let me just read this description
that i found online and probably the
person who asked the question is never
going to want to try marshmallows again
or gelatin again but this is how it
reads gelatin is made from animal
collagen
a protein that makes up connective
tissues such as skin
tendons ligaments and bones the hides
and bones of certain animals
often cows and pigs are boiled
dried treated with a strong acid or base
and finally filtered until a collagen is
extracted that would discourage me
immediately from even thinking about it
gelatin is a protein obtained by boiling
skin tendons ligaments and or bones with
water
it is usually obtained from cows or pigs
gelatin
gelatin is used in shampoos face masks
and other cosmetics as a thickener for
fruit
gelatins and puddings in candies
marshmallows cakes ice cream
and yogurts on photographic film and in
vitamins as coating and as capsules
and it is sometimes used to assist in
clearing wines
clearing in quotation marks gelatin is
not vegan
however there is a product called agar
agar
that is sometimes marketed as gelatin
but it is vegan yes
it is derived from a type of seaweed
which would discourage me also
because i don't like seeds but i've
tasted that one in portugal and it
it doesn't taste like seaweed so
[Laughter]
you know the seaweed has too much of a
fishy taste yeah
well they've de-fished it pasta so if
you had to you you
could but you know being a christian
i'll put it this way christ inserts
himself into every aspect of your life
yes
into he goes into your refrigerator he
goes into your wallet yeah he goes into
your guest book
he goes in to your social calendar
there's no part of your life that is not
of concern to christ
and he always wants our good so if
you've got to give up a little gelatin
when you get to heaven and look back
over your shoulder it's worth it yeah no
big deal
and i think what you mentioned pastor
gover is very very important and that is
when we go to the supermarket we have a
tendency just to take something off the
shelf and put it in the cart and go pay
for it
but it's so important to read labels to
to
you know inform ourselves not only when
it comes to gelatin
but when it comes to so many other
products you know when you
sometimes i read the list of ingredients
saying my
am i going to eat all of that you know
and a lot of things that are very
detrimental to health
so i think that uh i think it's the
lesson is
read the labels and abstain from
everything
that would perhaps have even the
appearance of evil
uh you know eat what god has created for
us to enjoy
amen from the vegetable world
amen amen okay as it says in genesis 1
and maybe we can just end with this time
is up god
said see i have given you every herb
that yields seed
which is on the face of all the earth
every tree whose fruit yields seed
to you it shall be for food amen
so god's way is the best way the
original diet
will keep us more healthy than if we
participate in everything that's
processed
amen well we want to thank you for being
with us
our time has flown by god bless you and
we hope to see you in our next program
i'd like to know
[Music]
you